[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to "Talks at Google."
Today's speaker is meteorologist
and "Celebrity MasterChef"
contestant Evelyn Cusack.
So let's give her
a warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
EVELYN CUSACK: Hi, thanks
very much for coming.
I'm going to tell you
a little bit about how
we forecast weather.
So if that's right, I'm
a little of meteorology.
So we can start--
this the view from the
European satellite--
Meteor sat.
Now, sorry, it's a bit fast.
But I know you're
all zippy here.
So already, there's Africa.
So the satellite is located
at 37,000 kilometers
over the equator and at
the 0 line longitude.
So you can see how tiny
Ireland is in this.
So this is a real view.
In atlases, their
vision is distorted.
So the best few
from the satellite
is actually over Africa.
Now, this stuff
here is-- the cloud
is the tropical thunderstorms.
And I think you can
see a connection there.
Do you see it's going
around that way?
So this is 2012.
Here's Ireland.
And all this white
stuff-- they are actually
a series of Atlantic storms
that have produced flooding.
And here's the dry,
sunny, hot Sahara Desert.
And here's the Patagonia
Desert down here.
So you've got the
desert belts here,
the tropical thunderstorms.
And then you've got
Atlantic westerlies.
And also, it's called
the [INAUDIBLE].
So that's the basic pattern
of weather around the world.
And Ireland just happens to lie
in the path of these Atlantic
westerlies.
So that's why it
rains quite a lot
and why it's not
dry, warm, and sunny.
If you want dry, warm,
and sunny weather,
go down here, all right?
Although I do feel if we were
only about 10 or 15 degrees
more south, it would be a
bit warmer and a bit dryer.
But all in all, it's pretty dry.
Now, I don't know if you
watch the weather on RTE.
But this is my
colleague Helen Curran.
So we actually
have a blue screen.
And we do point to the
blue screen at the back.
But we're not totally blind
as [INAUDIBLE] in the corner.
And we have a countdown
clock, which basically you
have about two minutes
for the broadcast.
So that 28 on means
it's 28 minutes to air.
So the broadcast is
about two minutes long.
Now, in the olden days,
they used to cut me off,
because I'd always go on longer.
[INAUDIBLE] things.
So I usually take
about 30 seconds.
Well, the news always look for
extra time, so to hell with it.
So here's what the viewer sees.
So now do you know what
these fluffy clouds are?
Does anyone watch
"The Simpsons"?
Yeah.
So they are "The
Simpsons" clouds.
They are cumulus clouds.
Now, if you look out
the window, there
aren't really cumulus clouds.
They are stratus clouds.
So stratus is the
Latin for a layer.
Whereas cumulus is
the Latin for heat.
Now, they're kind of nice,
little friendly, fluffy clouds.
But when they get very--
when the atmosphere
is very unstable,
they build up to the atmosphere.
And we get pretty violent clouds
that are called cumulonimbus.
Now, sometimes these are
formed near volcanoes,
because the volcanic
cash actually acts
as a seeding for the clouds.
So this is a nice website here
to get lots of nice images.
And so the cumulonimbus clouds
produce hail and thunderstorms.
And the clouds we saw
at the equator there--
they are cumulonimbus clouds.
So you can actually get
killed in one of these
from lightening.
And lots of these
produce tornadoes.
You know the "Wizard
of Oz" when Dorothy
was taken up in a tornado?
That came from a
cumulonimbus cloud.
Now, is anyone
here from Iceland?
Good.
So I'd pronounce it [INAUDIBLE].
That's fine.
So this is it looking
down from the Meteor sat.
So there's Iceland.
So there's the actual
volcanic cloud.
And you see Ireland
there in the corner.
So who said it always
rains in Ireland?
The white stuff is the clouds.
So it's pretty sunny
there in the west.
So I guess you'd like
to know how we actually
forecast the weather.
So we don't go to
our app on the phone,
because we produce
what's on the app.
So I'm going to tell you how
we do that now a little bit
hopefully.
So meteorology in Ireland
goes back quite a lot.
You've all heard of
Boyle's law, have you?
Studied physics in school.
So there's Robert Boyle,
1659, the famous gas law.
And this was one of the earlier
observatories in Ireland--
Phoenix Park, 1829.
So it's hard to see here-- but
taking his weather reading.
So scientific-- or
not forecasting--
the discussion of science in
Ireland goes back to the 1600s.
And the [INAUDIBLE] era, if
you want to call it [INAUDIBLE]
era, is when the
telegraphic cable was laid
from North America to Ireland.
If you like, it really was
the internet of its day.
So that's it.
And you can see it at the
National Maritime Museum
in [INAUDIBLE].
I meant to bring a sample of it.
I forgot my [INAUDIBLE].
Sorry about that.
The Irish Met Service,
where I work for,
really wasn't
established until 1937.
And [INAUDIBLE] in
1933, Charles Lindbergh
chose Foynes, County Limerick
as an essential eastern terminus
for the transatlantic
flight water route.
So going from North
America to Shannon--
so the weather was-- they
obviously needed a forecast.
So that's when we came into
existence, if you like.
It was to service.
Now, I shudder to think of the
flying conditions and forecasts
in those days.
But sure, it's
progressed anyway.
And everyone wasn't killed.
So here's an observer.
Do you know what that
screen is called?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
EVELYN CUSACK: [INAUDIBLE] yeah.
And the person that
designed that [INAUDIBLE],
he was the [INAUDIBLE]
the son of--
you know who kidnapped
Robert Louis Stevenson?
So here's all our stuff.
There's thermometers--
humidity measurement.
But most of our
stations [INAUDIBLE]
are actually automatic now.
So at Met Eireann, we build
our own weather stations.
And there's a colleague, Frank.
A lot of our older stations
have closed down actually.
We have one Kilkenny going
way back into early '50s.
And the reason it
had to close down
was the locals started
building houses
around it, which was very
inconsiderate of them,
because we need a
nice, open area,
because if you have
houses around, it
will interfere with
the wind direction.
It will also create a
little heat island load.
It's much more in the city
than out in the middle
of the country, because
the buildings actually
radiate heat.
So it's a well-known
phenomenon-- an urban heat
island, say in London, or Paris,
or New York, very large cities,
it can be up to 10 degrees
higher in the night than
in the adjoining.
So that's why you can
probably hear of a rural frost
or frost out in the country.
And sometimes we're forecasting
frost [INAUDIBLE] again.
But that's because
you live in the city.
So that's a good
excuse [INAUDIBLE].
So one of the main
things of importance
here at our web
station is this fence.
So do you think--
do you know?
OK, we obviously don't
want people breaking in.
But more importantly, we
don't little wild animals
coming in and interfering
with our rain reporter
and adding to the totals.
So, sorry, just a bit fuzzy.
But can you make out--
that's the Earth underneath.
That's a ship.
That's an airplane.
That's a weather balloon.
There's satellites.
So the WMO-- that's the World
Meteorological Organization,
who do an amazing amount
of observations now--
so 10,000 surface
weather stations
right around the
world, 1,000 upper-air.
The weather is obviously
three dimensional.
Most of our weather
occurs in the troposphere,
which is about 12 kilometers
up, which isn't very much when
you think of it.
It's really just 12 kilometers
between us and oblivion.
So if you have a
peach, or an apple,
the atmosphere is just
like the skin on the apple.
It's very little.
And the weather is
even a smaller part.
So in Ireland, we have two
upper-air weather stations.
We send up weather
balloons and [INAUDIBLE].
And then we have drifting
buoys, or boo-ees,
as we say in North America.
We have hundreds of weather
radars, commercial air check
observations, and then you
have 50, 60, 70 research
satellites-- weather
satellites, which
observe the climate,
not only at the weather,
but also the climate and the
condensation in the atmosphere.
Now, the first
step in a forecast
is you must observe
what's happening.
Just say, for example,
at midday today.
And then, after
years of research,
we figured out more or less
the physics of the atmosphere.
But I'm not going to go into it.
It's a nice picture
for you there.
So it's all the
different processes.
The sun shines on the Earth.
It goes through the atmosphere.
But you know it's usually that
the atmosphere doesn't observe
much of the sun's rays,
because otherwise, we
wouldn't see anything.
So, if you like, the
atmosphere is more or less
transparent to the sun's rays--
the light from the sun.
And in fact, the sun
heats up the ground.
And the ground
radiates out heat.
And that's what heats.
[INAUDIBLE] when you go
out in the sun, the sun
heats your skin.
But the sun doesn't heat the
air, because most of the air
is nitrogen and oxygen.
It's about 78% nitrogen
and 21% oxygen. So
what does that leave?
78% plus 21%.
So it only leaves 1% from
the other stuff, which
is water vapor,
which is the rain
and carbon dioxide [INAUDIBLE]
the greenhouse gases.
So anyway, we take
our observations.
We construct a meteorological
model using the known physics
of the atmosphere.
And then we feed them into
a very powerful computer,
which is our European Center
for Medium-range Weather
Forecasting.
Now, I just got this
from the ECMWF website--
2 quadrillion
calculations a second.
That's quite a lot, is it?
That's a quadrillion.
OK, we won't google it.
So that's supercomputer.
I was over visiting in summer.
And it was sort of like
visiting the mother ship
in this lovely movie.
We weren't allowed
to take photos.
And it was really cold.
Your engineer, who can
tell you all about it
from the data center,
is really freezing.
But we weren't
allowed to touch it.
But we were allowed
to worship it.
[LAUGHTER]
There's been a new upgrade
on [INAUDIBLE] summer.
So I just want to
explain a little bit.
OK, we have the physics
of the atmosphere.
And the weather is a
deterministic system
in the sense what is weather.
And each molecule
in the atmosphere--
each molecule would
have a kinetic energy.
Temperature is just
the movement of atoms.
So, if you like, weather is
a very deterministic system
in the sense if you know
what each molecule is doing
at one point in time,
using these equations,
you can predict forward in time.
The only problem is
there is so many of them
that we can't know what
each molecule is doing.
So we create mathematical grids.
And then of all of the millions
of molecules in each grid,
we smear it out and do
an average temperature,
if you like.
To forecast the weather,
the weather, as we saw,
it's going around, and around,
and around, and around,
and around.
The atmosphere is
spinning the Earth.
And the Earth is
going around the sun.
So we have these grids.
This is about 900 million grid
points at 9 kilometer spacing
between each grid point.
Now, this is for a global
model, so I just wanted to--
but for Ireland, we have what's
called a high-resolution model.
And our high-resolution
model have grid points
at 2.5 kilometer spacing.
And we're working towards
a 1 kilometer spacing.
So what it really
is is that we're
trying to model the surface
of the Earth and also
the atmosphere.
So it's going up 137 layers
up to the 12 kilometers.
I won't spend a
lot of time on it.
But the higher the
resolution, the more
we can model the atmosphere
better and the weather.
So each, if you like,
national met service,
we have our own
high-resolution models
for our own countries
and the area.
So we model the
Wicklow Mountains.
And then the Swiss
Weather Service
would be modeling the Alps.
You can imagine
what a nightmare it
is trying to forecast the
Alps with the valleys--
up and down up and down.
So this is an example plotted.
So we get that from our
model both from the ECMWF
and from our own harmony
high-resolution model.
And really, my job has
been very, very simple,
because I just interpret
this for you guys
and then go on television and
give you the weather forecast.
But there is such a limit.
And you've probably
heard of chaos
and all that sort of stuff.
It's very important [INAUDIBLE].
But we've reckoned at the moment
that 10 days ahead is the most.
And it's because-- remember I
said we can't know the initial
conditions perfectly,
because weather is--
for the millions, and
billions, and billions
of molecules in the
atmosphere, and we
can't model that perfectly.
So there's some certainty
in the initial conditions.
And those and
second just multiply
as you go forward in time.
So we've reckoned about
a week to 10 days ahead.
Now, maybe in 100 years time,
my colleague of the future
will be standing
here in front of you.
And maybe they'll play this
back and say, oh, so cute
to imagine they could only
forecast 10 days ahead.
So hopefully that will be true.
That's how we think
now at this stage.
When I started at first, I
started on television in 1998,
it was really even
scarier because we weren't
even didn't had a lot of
confidence tomorrow's forecast,
but you sure had
to give it anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
So I have gone on TV.
I had to make sure I wasn't
wearing the same jacket.
Actually, I just had
5 to 10 days ahead,
because a lot of the
media and certain websites
were like-- it's going
to be a cold winter.
It's going to be a
fantastic summer.
Well, if there
were forecasts that
could forecast that time ahead,
sure, I would give it to you.
That's my job.
It's not as if [INAUDIBLE],
or in the British Met Office--
oh, we know it's going
to be a good summer.
But we're not
going to tell them.
They have some type of secret.
And I'll give you a
concrete example of this.
We have to apply for--
there's just about
12 to 14 forecasters
working in the met area.
And we're a very
small met service.
Because I'm one of the oldest,
I'm on top of the roster.
So I have to take my
summer leave in January,
which is kind of annoying.
So if I knew the
forecast for the summer,
I would obviously
pick the best time.
So way back in 1995, it was the
hottest and the driest summer
on record.
Where's [INAUDIBLE].
I don't know.
So the three weeks I picked
was the only break in weather
in that long, hot summer.
So for my three weeks, it
rained almost continuously.
And four weeks before it
and four weeks after it,
it was warm and sunny.
So I would be silly not to
use that forecast [INAUDIBLE].
So we go 10 days ahead.
But I just want to
show you this now.
I know your head will
hurt looking at this.
So it's [INAUDIBLE].
And I just picked it up.
This is called
ensemble forecasting.
So just look at precipitation--
precipitation is anything
that falls from the sky.
So it's rain, sleet, snow,
hail, drizzle, so anything
that falls from the
sky is precipitation.
So this is yesterday's forecast.
It was similar to today.
Here's Wednesday the
8th, 9th, 10th, 11th--
so pretty much dry.
Look.
So there's a little bit.
But you can see
there is a spread.
So what we do is
because we don't
know the initial stage of
the atmosphere perfectly,
we run the model 52 times by
perturbing the initial state.
We vary certain parts
of the atmosphere
that we have uncertainty about.
And we run it 52 times.
Again, maybe in 100 years time,
they'll say, oh, it's so cute.
They ran the model 52 times.
Maybe they'll be running it a
million times with a million
different perturbation
at that stage.
But you know, ECMWF--
it's the world leader in
medium-range forecasting.
So by medium range, we're
talking about 10 days.
So this is an ensemble.
It's sort of a
probability, if you like.
Now, in Ireland, we don't really
use probability forecasting
much, because our
weather is so variable.
It's easier-- see if you're
forecasting for, let's say,
Dublin or New York, you can
give more of a probability
for one moment in
time or for a midday,
or for a particular day.
But for a whole country,
and for a climate like ours,
we can actually vary
from rain and showers.
Now, do you know the different
between rain and showers?
So I'm going to tell you.
But anyway, Met Eirann-- that's
where I work in Glasnevin.
So our first mission statement--
"Ensure the protection and
safety of life and property
by issuing a public weather
forecast and warnings."
So if there was a method of
forecasting a really bad winter
ahead, that's my job.
That's what the
public pay me for.
So I would use it.
So let's move on, Evelyn.
Let's get off this fence here.
So here's Ireland.
So you are probably
familiar with [INAUDIBLE],
Mizen Head, Slyne Head.
Have you heard the
weather forecast?
So we issue all these forecasts.
And recently, we've
issued a warning system--
so yellow, orange, and red.
Thankfully, we haven't done
any red warnings this year.
It's been a very
quiet winter so far.
We defined winter as December,
January, and February
in Ireland.
The reason we do in that
space are temperature.
And these are the coldest
months except for this year.
So when I was
growing up, we used
to define spring as the
first of February, which
is St. Brigid's Day.
But that's based more in light.
You know the way it's getting
brighter in the evenings.
But statistically
and meteorologically,
the coldest months in Ireland
and in the Northern Hemisphere
are December,
January, and February.
So it doesn't matter how
you define something,
as long as everybody knows
why you're defining it.
Shakespeare said that.
You know, what's in a name?
Is it a rose?
Blah, blah, blah.
A rose is just as sweet by
any other name or whatever.
That's what's important
in science, isn't it?
That we all have
the same definition.
It doesn't matter.
In fact, that's language.
Personally, I have no
interest in languages,
or studying languages, because
it's not real knowledge.
It's just what people
are using as words.
But it's important
to communications.
But there are all
different criteria we use.
I'm not going to
go through them.
It's too boring.
Except for winds.
Status red.
We used a status red
warning when we expect winds
over 130 kilometers per hour.
Now, we're part of the European
consortium of Meteoalarm.
This is very good.
If you're ever
traveling around Europe,
you get this on our website or
the Meteoalarm Ireland website.
And it gives an idea
of severe weather.
So recently, that analysis--
if you ever go skiing,
it was warning of avalanches.
And these are all the countries
and models [INAUDIBLE].
That would be handy for the
Eurovision, wouldn't it?
So I know Google are actually
in talks with [INAUDIBLE]
to use this idea.
So it's very good,
because these warnings
are issued by all the
national met services.
So there's a lot of independent
weather companies around now,
which is great.
It's fine.
But it's important that
there's a warning--
that there aren't all these
spurious warnings, I think.
So the official warnings
for severe weather in Europe
are done by the
meteorological services.
And I think we all work
to the same standards
and have scientific conferences.
So again, we don't want
spurious warnings--
it's going to be a
really cold winter
with severe thunderstorms,
and blizzards, and everything.
So [INAUDIBLE].
So from last year, we are in
collaboration with the British
Met Office naming storms.
So do you remember
any of these storms?
So Barney-- [INAUDIBLE] Desmond
gave you a lot of flooding.
And in fact, the midlands was
flooded for several months
from Storm Desmond.
And it's been a very
quiet winter this year.
We haven't really
had any storms.
And this just affected
southern parts of Britain.
The way we're doing it is if we
expect an Atlantic storm to hit
any part of Ireland,
England, Wales, or Scotland--
is anybody from Ireland,
England, Wales, Scotland?
Yeah.
We're going to name it.
So we've had none this year.
Now, I'm on the committee
to name the storm.
So I will take all bribes.
[LAUGHTER]
And I've got my
daughter in here, Fleur.
So I wasn't sure.
If it turns out
to be a bad storm,
a Fleur caused destruction.
But in fact, it may
not even happen yet,
because we haven't
even had a storm.
Now I shouldn't say we have
a couple of months left.
But certainly, as you saw
in our ECMWF medium range,
we expect pretty quiet
conditions for the next week
to 10 days.
But the storm naming
goes back a while--
so the Ulysses storm of 1903.
The reason it's called
the Ulysses Storm
is James Joyce's
really boring novel
"Ulysses," which
is supposed to be
one of the greatest works
of literature of all time.
Hands up who's read it.
AUDIENCE: I can't
remember any of it.
EVELYN CUSACK: In fact, I
even joined a study group
studying it, you know--
just--
[LAUGHTER]
"Finnegan's Wake" is worse.
I know [INAUDIBLE]--
scientist [INAUDIBLE].
So that's a recreation
of the storm.
Obviously, there
were no warnings.
Oh, yeah, it knocked
down almost 3,000 trees.
Try and say that--
3,000 trees in the Phoenix Park.
But this is what a storm
looks like from satellite--
from the Meteor sats.
Everything is in swirls
in our Universe, isn't it?
So at Ireland's
latitudes, our weather
is in constant [INAUDIBLE]
between colder coming down
from the north and warmer
coming up from the south.
So where the two
air masses clash,
you get what's known
as a frontal zone.
The reason it's
called a weather front
is that the meteorologist
Vilhelm Bjerknes from Norway
discovered this, if you
like, from observation.
It was during World War
I in the Western Front.
So we likened the weather
front as two opposing armies--
the warm and cold.
So I'm now going to explain to
you the difference between rain
and showers.
So our rain is at the front.
So it lasts for several hours.
It could last for a day.
So can you think back--
when did we last have rain?
On Monday.
So that was a front, because
it lasted for many hours,
didn't it?
And then the rain could
clear, and beautiful sunshine,
and sunshine and showers.
So some people said, oh, you're
really hedging your bets,
aren't you?
Right here in
sunshine and showers.
But you remember we saw the
cumulonimbus with the hail
and the thunderstorm.
That occurs in these clouds--
cumulus-- cumulonimbus.
And this is the stratus,
which is just gentle.
But you can get very
poor visibility there.
So does anyone do hill walking?
Yeah, so never go hill walking
when there's a front coming in.
And you can find that from that
[INAUDIBLE] from the radar,
because that's really good.
That can you show
you the actual rain.
So better move on.
But you know "Crocodile Dundee"?
You know that saying,
you call that a knife?
Well, this is,
call that a storm?
But unfortunately
Hurricane Mitch--
it was a devastating hurricane.
I know Hurricane Katrina
gets all the-- you know,
was really bad flooding.
But this was
actually devastating.
It hit Central America.
And there isn't the
same infrastructure.
And even though
it was warned of,
it's not as easy to evacuate,
because where do you go?
There's all these mountains.
And over 9,000 people died, even
though forecasters knew-- we
could see it on the satellite.
And this is 1998.
And I remember working,
and it was, god,
look at the size of it.
And it went right in
across Central America--
absolutely devastating.
So in fact, I just
checked last night.
9,000 people died.
9,000 people are missing.
So even though you
can forecast, it
isn't always possible
obviously to save people.
And that's satellite, which
is looking down from space--
this is a weather radar.
And here is the difference
again between rain and showers.
So there's rain, and
there's [INAUDIBLE] showers.
Is that all right?
So radar-- this
isn't a forecast.
Radar sends out radio pulses.
And it's reflected back.
And it shows you where
your precipitation is.
So use radar if you're going
out for a walk or whatever,
and you can judge
the weather yourself.
So here is our
rainfall stations.
We actually have about
500 rainfall stations now.
And it looks like
a map of Ireland.
But it's actually a map
of the annual rainfall.
So most of the rain
occurs at mountains,
because when the air
comes across the Atlantic,
it's full of moisture.
And it can go
through a mountain.
So it rises up, and then
you get precipitation out.
So here is a very wet place--
very wet.
So these are the mountains.
But look at Dublin.
So if you can read the legend
there, it's between 0 and 600--
[INAUDIBLE]
The annual rainfall in Dublin
at the greater Dublin area
is just about 800
or 900 millimeters.
So Dublin actually is one of
the driest parts of the country.
And one of the reasons is
because just south of us we
have the Wicklow Mountains.
So a lot of our rain comes
in from the Atlantic.
As it's coming in, the
wind becomes southerly.
So the rain falls
out of the Wicklows.
So especially on the southern
side of the Wicklow Mountains,
it's a very wet spot.
And it's hard to read these,
but these are annual sunshine.
So winter-- I just have written
it in rather quickly here.
[INAUDIBLE] sunshine
in the Northwest--
225.
So maybe a part of the saying
the sunny side of the East
[INAUDIBLE] really is true.
In the summer, 600,l but
you know all of the eastern
[INAUDIBLE].
That's again, because
a lot of our weather
comes in from the
Atlantic, and it's actually
basically dried out by the
time it gets to the east.
But we can get very
bad weather in Dublin
when it's coming
in from the east.
So the highest speed ever
is 98 knots [INAUDIBLE].
And I'm not comparing it to all
around the world [INAUDIBLE].
The highest ever
temperature-- at 33.
Now, back on our
warnings-- what?
AUDIENCE: So the Europeans
are laughing at the--
[LAUGHTER]
EVELYN CUSACK: Yeah, I know.
I know.
Actually, I'm not
going to talk back.
But we actually issue
weather warnings
if we expect
temperature of over 27.
So I'm almost delighted to say--
so we actually issue a
red alert if ti's over 30.
And that's just a
balmy summer's day.
So I won't go back, but you
know the Meteoalarm one.
So a red for Ireland is nothing
for the south, for Sicily.
So each country, each national
met service, issue warnings
for their own area
that can affect
their own citizens relative
to their own types of weather.
[INAUDIBLE]
So at what time were you--
AUDIENCE: Three more minutes.
EVELYN CUSACK: Three minutes?
Jeepers, OK, we're going to
zip through the entire time
to [INAUDIBLE].
So the Earth is 4.5
billion years old.
So there's been loads
of different climates.
At one stage, we think there
was actually a snowball Earth.
All of the Earth
was covered in ice.
But we're going to zip along now
to about 370 million years ago.
It's very interesting.
Has anyone been to
Valentia Island?
It's a very interesting place.
You can look at where the first
transatlantic telegraph station
came in and also these tracks.
It was discovered by a young
geology student from UCD
in the 1980s.
And they're actually-- you know
we all started off like, well,
that's bacteria first of all.
We all think we come from eggs.
But in fact, we all
started off as bacteria
4 billion years ago.
Then we evolved
underneath the sea.
And then somehow 370 million
years ago-- well, not suddenly,
of course, we crawled out.
And the first tracks
of the first tetrapods
can be seen on Valentia Island.
But at that stage, Ireland
had a lovely, balmy climate--
beautiful tropical climate.
But we went through a
series-- actually, just to--
I don't have a graphic.
You know the way all the
continents of the world
are all drifting around?
It's called clay tectonics
where our modern climate really
wasn't established until
4 million years ago--
very near.
The age of the Earth is
4.5 billion years ago.
But 4 million years
ago, South America
drifted north to create
the Isthmus of Panama.
And that cut off the Atlantic
Ocean from the Pacific Ocean.
And that set off
the Gulf Stream.
And that's when our modern
climate was established.
So when you hear all this
thing about global warming
and, oh, sure, what
are they talking about?
It was much warmer in the past.
When the dinosaurs roamed the
Earth, it was much more, yes,
we know.
But when the dinosaurs
roamed the Earth,
we had one supercontinent
called Pangea.
Basically, the Earth was
one giant desert that
stretched from pole to pole.
So when we're talking about
climate change at the north,
it's really only in relation
to the last 4 million years.
And we get a good information
about the climate of that time
from the ice cores in
Antarctica essentially.
But the last ice age
ended 12,000 years ago.
And really, that's when
our modern civilizations
has taken off--
mathematics, literature,
drawing, art, et cetera.
And in fact, in 1859, an Irish
man there-- he looks cute--
John Tyndall.
He actually a lot of why
the sky is blue and first
described global warming.
He predicted it in 1859,
which is quite shocking really
that it was so long ago.
Some possible climate
change for Ireland.
We're not sure, obviously.
It hasn't happened yet.
But a sea level rise
looks pretty definite,
because the sea temperatures
are increasing a lot.
And when you increase
the temperature
of the sea, what happens?
The molecules start
vibrating more,
and they get further apart.
And then physically,
the sea expands.
You get more evaporation
then, because when
the sun shines on the sea,
it gives the water molecules
more energy.
And some of them evaporate.
So you do get more clouds,
perhaps more precipitation,
and a higher sea level.
That's unequivocal.
How it will affect the
weather systems as such
is more problematic,
because the weather
is a very complicated system.
I'll [INAUDIBLE].
It doesn't matter.
But this is a temperature chart
from 1900 to 2015 or something.
And it's a global temperature.
There's quite a dip there, but
it has been steadily rising.
And Ireland is part
of that trend .
And you can read more
about it on our website,
and the Royal Irish
Academy Professor Ray Bates
is one of the world's
leaders in that.
But even though the climate
is getting warmer, of course,
we get colder interludes.
And does anyone remember that?
That was only 2010.
And there was a frost
and icing in Dublin,
even in the urban heat island.
I'm going to end with
this Hubble picture
just because I like it.
So where Ireland, or
the world, the Earth
is in our own solar system,
we have one little sun.
And we're literally the
third rock from the sun.
And we say we're in
the Goldilocks zone,
because we have
developed in this zone.
So our solar system
is just belonging
to one star in maybe 200
billion stars in our own galaxy.
And then looking out, there is--
I don't know--
billions and billions
or 100 billion galaxies
that we know of out there.
So with all of this
knowledge, the latest thinking
from cosmologists
is that we've heard
of dark matter and dark energy.
And everything we can see--
all the physical things we can
see--
only 5% of the
observable Universe.
So we don't [INAUDIBLE].
So that's why I have to say--
young people of the world-- we
need you to study science,
maths, everything-- et cetera.
So that's my little
homily ending.
So these are some of the
little slides that we used.
And thank you for
your attention.
And I am showing this,
because it's very unusual.
This is a visual
satellite of Ireland.
You can actually see Ireland.
Now, there isn't a yellow
line around Ireland.
[INAUDIBLE] picturing one group.
Let's put it on afterwards,
because a lot of the time,
Ireland is covered in clouds.
So we just-- we can see
the outline in the yellow.
So this is very unusual.
When was it?
2015-- April-- hmm.
And this white stuff here
actually isn't cloud.
Well, it is cloud.
It's sea fog.
What we define fog is
a cloud with no legs.
So I think that's it.
Oh, yeah.
I have one more.
In case you were
going to ask me.
Nobody asked me, is it
going to be a nice summer?
And animals and plants can't
predict weather, all right?
Although I know you guys
wouldn't think that.
Would you like me to
give you some homework?
So has anyone watched "Cosmos"?
Yeah, OK, so when I was growing
up, Carl Sagan on the right--
he's my hero, who is an
American professor of physics.
And he started off [INAUDIBLE]
science communication.
And you can get his
series on YouTube.
The graphics are
kind of cute now.
But if you just listen
to him, he's amazing.
And it's just been
remade recently
by Neil DeGrasse Tyson.
So it's certainly
worth the time when
you're finished
watching "Breaking Bad"
or whatever you guys watch.
And here's some nice,
light reading for you.
OK, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES MORRIS: Hi, how are you?
I'm James Morris.
[INAUDIBLE], if you haven't.
I am one of you guys.
I'm a googler.
And my job is brilliantly
affected by what
you see outside in the water.
I work for the data
center in Dublin.
And we're the only data
center in the global fleet
that depend on [INAUDIBLE].
Would you look out there?
You see the clouds.
It's not too hot.
It's not too cold.
We've [INAUDIBLE].
This is exactly what we need--
exactly what we need.
All right?
[INAUDIBLE] to cool the data
center, we open the window.
To check the weather,
we stick our hand out.
If it's get wet, it's raining.
If it gets cold, it's windy--
not fully true, all right?
We use what's
called air handlers.
And we have air side cooling.
So every data
center in the fleet
uses cooling towers, which
consume a huge amount of water
for cooling air, all right?
[INAUDIBLE] there and
are pretty much steady,
ambient temperature
all year round.
We suck cold air
into the big fans
in the side of the building
into the data center floor.
All right?
Any idea of what the temperature
of the data center floor is?
Any guesses?
AUDIENCE: 12 Celsius?
JAMES MORRIS: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: 15?
JAMES MORRIS: Someone has
been to the data center.
It's at 27.
AUDIENCE: 27 what?
JAMES MORRIS: 27 degrees?
That's the ambient temperature
inside the data hall.
EVELYN CUSACK: Celsius?
JAMES MORRIS: Celsius.
EVELYN CUSACK: Orange warning.
JAMES MORRIS: [INAUDIBLE].
We need technicians to
work at the Eastern Shores
for data center
floor and all that.
All right?
So the building
is designed to run
at a fairly warm
temperatures we have
that's most efficient, which
means that this is perfect.
At times, this weather
is actually is even
too cold for what we want.
And we recirculate
the waste hot air
from the rack of servers
out to the air handlers,
mix it with cold air coming in,
and control our temperatures.
And we have what's called a BMS,
a Building Management System,
which automatically keeps the
temperature at the set point.
So it's set pressure--
roughly a set humidity,
but we're not too
concerned about humidity,
and it's set at
winter at 27 degrees.
All right?
So if you look out
and say, oh, god,
I hate the weather in
Ireland, I want to go back
to where I come from--
I want to go to Spain--
whatever-- this is perfect.
This is boring.
And as Ben Treynor, one of the
top guys in Google always says,
boring is good.
This is good for us.
All right?
EVELYN CUSACK:
[INAUDIBLE] boring.
JAMES MORRIS: Irish weather.
Irish weather.
OK, so you want to
start Q&A, all right?
I want to ask the
first question.
I think it's a very
important question.
Evelyn, you said that
animals and plants
can't predict the weather.
Can postmen in New Zealand
predict the weather?
AUDIENCE: And [INAUDIBLE].
EVELYN CUSACK: [INAUDIBLE]?
Do you really want me to answer?
Can I sit here?
No, because if they
could, as I said,
we would use their forecasts,
especially [INAUDIBLE].
Animals and plants respond
to current conditions.
The weather that hits Ireland
in five days time, or in 10 days
time, doesn't exist yet.
The weather that hit
Ireland in five days time
is usually at the other side
of the Atlantic [INAUDIBLE].
So animals can't possibly know.
How could they?
Think logically.
JAMES MORRIS:
Hollywood design then?
EVELYN CUSACK:
Hollywood design, yeah.
And plants actually respond
to current conditions
as well and growing conditions.
So when I was growing up,
there was a saying, oh,
if the trees, or the
bushes, the hedgerows,
have a lot of berries, it
means Mother Nature is looking
after the little birdies, and
it's going to be a hard winter.
We'll know.
Mother Nature is pretty
cruel essentially,
because at the moment, there
is thousands of little birdies
been eaten alive, aren't they?
So Mother Nature-- sorry,
it's for your lunch.
Mother Nature isn't looking
out for little birdies.
The reason there's
a lot of berries
on the trees, et
cetera, is because it
was a very good growth season.
The spring was very good-- so
sorry to burst your bubble.
JAMES MORRIS: OK, so we'll
open it to the floor.
Has anybody any questions?
[INAUDIBLE]?
Shout if you want.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
So I actually used the
word yesterday [INAUDIBLE]
Irish phrase that we always
say, red sky at night,
shepherd's delight.
Red sky in the morning,
shepherd's warning,
meaning if it's red at night,
[INAUDIBLE] the next day,
[INAUDIBLE].
Is there any truth to it?
EVELYN CUSACK: Well,
there is a little bit.
But it doesn't always work.
So it's pretty useless then.
But there was a lovely
red sky yesterday morning.
So we actually said in
the weather office, ooh,
all the shepherd's
would be worried,
but we know it's
not going to rain.
So there is some truth to it.
It's to do with
the weather coming
in from the west and all that.
There's sort of truth.
But being serious, if you
go back 100 years, 50 years,
there's no such thing
as weather forecasts.
So people had to use--
not science or nature.
That always sounds like
science and nature.
But to try and
judge the weather--
so sometimes it is a sign
that fine weather is coming in
or wet weather is coming in.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there
rationale for sunny Monday
through Friday
and rainy weekend?
EVELYN CUSACK: Well, we
actually have that saying--
rain is brought on by
bank holiday weekends.
Yeah, and the fine weather
occurs during the [INAUDIBLE].
So, yeah.
No, there's no rationale at all.
I take if we're working
Monday to Friday,
we don't notice the
weather so much.
And then you want to go out on
the weekend, and it's raining,
you really notice that usually--
doesn't rain very
much in Dublin anyway.
Did I tell you the
weather is good?
Huh?
AUDIENCE: It's lovely.
EVELYN CUSACK: It's lovely.
Does everyone here
work in Dublin?
If you were over in
Donegal or Galway,
it is very beautiful there.
But it rains three,
four five times as much.
AUDIENCE: In terms of the
warnings that you issue.
That only started
last year [INAUDIBLE].
EVELYN CUSACK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It seems that you
err on the side of issuing
a warning rather than not
issuing a warning [INAUDIBLE].
It always seems like always a
warning, and then [INAUDIBLE].
EVELYN CUSACK: Nothing happens.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
the weather anyway.
But, yeah, nothing
happens there.
It's not as bad as it appears.
EVELYN CUSACK: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
agents are [INAUDIBLE] that.
And it wasn't quite
as bad as I imagined.
EVELYN CUSACK: No,
I suppose it varies.
Generally the worst of
the winter-- the West
and the Northwest-- the storms
are tracking it that way.
So if we had an orange
warning out for Dublin--
I think we did actually.
I can't remember.
The thing about wind
is that some areas--
we're confined to a county.
So some areas can
get it stronger
than others, because you
get effects with wind.
So I don't know that we--
we shouldn't err on
the side of caution.
But at some place
in the county, we
would hope that those
strong winds would occur--
not hope, predict.
So I'm sorry about
your experience.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
EVELYN CUSACK: No, no, no.
That's fine.
But do be careful, because
I'm a cyclist myself.
And you can get that-- shhh,
yeah, where did that come from?
So, obviously, if there
is an orange warning out,
it is probably going to
hopefully windy at some stage.
So it may not be when
you cycle in the morning.
But it might be in the evening.
So just be careful.
But in my experience,
the forecasts
have improved enormously.
And one of the reasons--
well, not one of the reasons.
The reason is that our
meteorological models
have improved
enormously due to better
modeling of the atmosphere
and increased computing power.
But as I said, there
probably will be a limit.
But our [INAUDIBLE] and
high-resolution models
we're working towards
a 1 kilometer grid,
so maybe in the next
five years or so that
will improve even further.
But there's always going
to be uncertainties.
And what's really
kind of annoying--
Ireland is such a small country.
But it's not that we
have different climates,
but because of the
mountains and that,
as you saw in that
rainfall chart--
a lot of the time, we're,
as forecasters talk
about rain coming in
from the Atlantic,
and it's [INAUDIBLE] eastwards.
But you saw there
how dry Dublin is.
The Wicklow Mountains take a
lot of the rain from Dublin.
So really Dublin should
have its own forecast.
But if I can't mention
Dublin on TV at night--
I'd just be shot.
On the lee side
of the mountains,
it's going to be dryer,
because the windward side takes
the rain.
But it just so happens that
Dublin, a million and a half
people, live on the lee side
of the Wicklow Mountains.
And it is very dry here.
So really we're
right all the time.
It's just Dublin.
JAMES MORRIS: Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
Have you ever met Michael Fish?
And have you ever had
a Michael Fish moment?
EVELYN CUSACK: Well, not yet,
but I think Michael passed away
during the summer, didn't he?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
EVELYN CUSACK: No,
but I haven't met him.
I go over to the met office.
We do collaborate a lot.
[INAUDIBLE]
Have I had a
Michael Fish moment?
Well, I've often given
totally incorrect forecasts
unfortunately--
nothing huge as yet.
But each day is a new day.
And doing live broadcasting--
I always figure the
worst has happened
or anything that can
happen has happened.
But there's always something
new to surprise me.
For example, last
year or the year
before, I was literally
doing my live broadcast
after the 9 o' clock news.
And suddenly, the lights
went out in the studio.
And I know it seems stupid.
I should have known that people
actually couldn't see anything.
Or maybe it's television.
They couldn't see it.
I can't see it.
That was just stupid.
But I just kept doing it anyway.
And then I ran
around afterwards.
Who turned off the lights?
And somebody actually turned
the lights off in the studio.
And he said, I thought
you were finished.
Did you look at the television?
And then another time.
For example, I
dropped the flicker.
And then I actually
did pick it up.
Because we had to move
it on like, you know--
drop it.
And literally, we
don't have radio mics.
So there's a mic hanging on.
So I'm just waiting for
when I trip over it.
I shouldn't say that.
It's going to happen.
Very early on in my career, I
was on a program, an afternoon
show, telling the weather.
And there was a veterinary
slot afterwards following.
And they had swans
in the studio.
The swan went berserk.
So that was fun.
But he didn't actually come
in and gouge my eyes out.
JAMES MORRIS: OK, [INAUDIBLE].
One more question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I looked at the
[INAUDIBLE] later
[INAUDIBLE], and as
you said, [INAUDIBLE].
What I did notice
[INAUDIBLE] west
will be waiting
for ages to hear.
And [INAUDIBLE].
And I've just
started this course.
Would [INAUDIBLE]?
EVELYN CUSACK: It might
have something, yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you're expecting--
[INAUDIBLE] 15 minutes.
[INAUDIBLE]
EVELYN CUSACK: Yeah, it's
really annoying for me
as a meteorologist.
So it's really nice if
you have a rain in Dublin,
because if it doesn't
rain in Dublin,
it feels as if the
forecast is wrong.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
I think it's actually what
[INAUDIBLE] three days
and not rain, but we will
think of the weather being
bad [INAUDIBLE].
EVELYN CUSACK: Yeah, but I
think if you're a cyclist,
you can increase it.
There is few mornings it's
actually raining, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], but
especially this winter.
EVELYN CUSACK: This winter is
really incredible, yeah, so
far.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
this week [INAUDIBLE].
Dublin gets cold.
EVELYN CUSACK: So the wind?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
EVELYN CUSACK: Oh, yeah,
so leave the [INAUDIBLE].
So maybe this is status orange.
It's true [INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, the heat could cause it
literally to evaporate as it--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
EVELYN CUSACK: The rain
could be falling down,
and then the heat will
cause it to evaporate.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
EVELYN CUSACK: Yeah.
So Dublin is one of the
driest and warmest parts
of the country.
So welcome to our world.
JAMES MORRIS: I just want to
end it with two small questions.
So when I told my sons I was
coming today to meet Evelyn,
they were very excited.
My 11 year old--
his name is Ewan.
I confirm Storm
Ewan has started.
EVELYN CUSACK: Oh!
SPEAKER 2: All right?
It's well underway till 12.
It's getting worse.
EVELYN CUSACK: Oh, gosh.
SPEAKER 2: He asked me the
question every child asks,
all right?
What's your favorite weather?
EVELYN CUSACK: What's
my favorite weather?
OK.
22 degrees-- sunny sky--
maybe a little bit of cumulus--
you have the [INAUDIBLE]
"Simpsons" cumulus--
just maybe a little bit-- and
a gentle breeze of about 7
knots--
and a glass of Chablis--
maybe fried hocks.
JAMES MORRIS: And finally, my
nine-year-old son, Devin, never
looks at the weather-- couldn't
care less about the weather,
all right?
But he does watch the "Late,
Late Toy Show" on repeat
for about six months
into the year every year
and wanted to know what it
was like to be on [INAUDIBLE].
EVELYN CUSACK: Well, it was
a great privilege for me
to be asked.
So this little boy
made a weather game.
And he wanted to meet
a weather person.
And so I was asked on.
So it was kind of scary.
But yeah, it was
a great privilege,
because it is the most
watched program followed,
of course, by the weather.
So yeah, it was very nice, yeah.
JAMES MORRIS: We actually
watched it last night.
It was little Johnny from Ennis.
EVELYN CUSACK: Little
Johnny [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES MORRIS: And the
game was [INAUDIBLE].
EVELYN CUSACK: Yeah,
and he gave me a copy.
But I had actually mentioned
before, because sometimes I
give talks around the country.
And he actually came to my talk.
His mother emailed me for it--
would it be OK to bring him?
Because he was only nine, and
he had school the next day.
I said, yeah, bring him out.
Just bring out a pillow,
a duvet in the car,
so he can fall asleep
on the way home.
So he did come.
So that was nice.
JAMES MORRIS: OK, so on behalf
of Google and [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you very
much for your time.
EVELYN CUSACK: Oh,
thanks for having me
It's lovely to meet you.
JAMES MORRIS: I hope
everybody enjoyed it .
[APPLAUSE]
EVELYN CUSACK: [INAUDIBLE]
thank you very much.
And keep following [INAUDIBLE]
weather, all right?
Don't forget-- oh, we are
issuing a new app in summer,
so hopefully--
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you.